Formula One and its owner Liberty Media
are making their biggest bet to date
going all in on Las Vegas after 40 years
F1 will return right here to Sin City
racing cars down the strip at 200 miles
an hour why Vegas every major sport
seems to be coming here right now
whether it's the NFL the NHL the WNBA or
the UFC
what you've seen is the evolution of a
town to really Embrace a wider group of
Travelers and visitors it's no longer a
place where you just go spend the
weekend and you know what happens in
Vegas stays in Vegas it's now a place
where you actually want to go it's a
destination I give them a lot of credit
for transforming this town it wasn't
until recently that we at Liberty Media
had the opportunity to really take
Formula One to the next level in the
United States through the explosion of
popularity from Netflix as well as just
Americans beginning to embrace the sport
more and more younger demographic more
female demographic the timing was
absolutely right
f1's the hottest sport in America right
now Las Vegas will join Miami and Austin
as the third U.S based Grand Prix Vegas
is tailor-made for this sort of event
there are 150 000 hotel rooms within
walking distance of the track that may
mean that Vegas soon becomes one of the
most important dates on the F1 calendar
[Music]